How do we do writes to this memory?
Obviously, we need to
change one of the cells.
How do we do that?
We use the row address to
select the row of the cell, but
we can only select a whole row of cells.
We cannot just select an individual
cell, so if this is bit number 7 in our
32 bit world,
we select the address of the word, and
then we want to supply a bit here,
Let's say A1, to be written here.
So how do we do that?
Because we can only select a whole row.
Once we select a row, all these cells
get connected to the bit lines.
We can maybe derive the bit length for
this one to write a 1.
But that would lose us these bits.
So the way the write needs to happen, is
we use the row address, select the row,
read out these bits,
the sense amp amplifies them and
we latch them into the row buffer.
Now we write this bit to the row
buffer at this position,
and now we write the whole
thing back into the cells.
The cells lost their values
when we did the read, anyway.
We will have to write the values back,
anyway.
Before we do that, we make all
the writes that we want to that row, and
then send them back, so
that when we are writing,
we end up writing 1 1 1 and
this bit is changed to 1.
So a write in the run is also a read and
then write operation.